a movie or a tv show or both
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
so as you know i've just done a video
you may have seen it about the twitter
storm and um the executives at amazon
requesting reports based on
what has been going on and how
interested people really are in the
stargate franchise
well i can now tell you as well after
speaking to other sources that it does
seem to be more and more likely i would
say almost 100 percent
the stargate will be returning to our
screens and that actually it is not
going to be a choice between a movie or
a tv show they are planning both
so i can actually tell you what is being
looked at at the moment by reports from
um somebody that works in and around
jennifer sulk and what she's been
requesting and she is the head of amazon
studios
so according to the people i speak to
yes there is a movie being planned for
stargate and kurt russell has already
been approached to potentially return to
that movie
but they have a clever little plan on
how to do that movie without pissing
over cannon which i'll tell you about in
a minute
there is also the possibility that
brad's right script that was written
over three years ago for mgm could still
be produced and that is still being
considered but
it is not likely the chances are that if
brad wright does return as the
showrunner which again is very very
possible there would be a request for
him to rewrite the script or rework it
very heavily and to fit in with the now
wider project that is planned for the
stargate franchise
there is also two other projects being
considered one put it very basically
they've done very very early preliminary
thinking about what they would do if
brad wright doesn't return
and who they might approach about doing
a new series um but what i'm told is
that in very very early stages of
consideration
the other fourth project that is
seriously being considered is an ancient
prequel
um apparently they have gone as far as
having an idea of where a story arc
would go and
writers and a producer have been
approached but nothing has been
confirmed to clarify we basically have
four stargate projects seriously being
considered right now at amazon a movie
the brad wright project or a project
that brad wright would still run a third
project that would be run without brad
wright and they've gone as far as
considering who that other showrunner
might be
or and a fourth prequel series that
would be based in and around the
ancients
so how could they do a movie with kurt
russell without penal over canon well
from what i'm told producers and people
at amazon and mgm are not bothered in
the slightest that kurt russell would
return and they don't see that this has
any real impact on sg1 sg or sga or it
has to affect canon at all
they've swapped out actors before actors
from the stargate original movie
appeared in the series and so they don't
believe that that's necessarily a
problem if kurt russel was to return and
kurt russell if they do do a movie at
the end of the day is a bigger draw than
richard dean anderson they believe at
least for the wider audience stargate
fans would want richard dean anderson
somebody new would want to watch a movie
with kurt russell is generally the
thinking
now how could they do this without
destroying canon because for what i'm
told this will be
set up as a sequel to the original movie
kind of
well the plan is to do a very specific
storyline kurt russell would be the
center of that storyline as general
o'neal and the story would be focused on
an off-world planet
the idea being that the story would be
so focused they just simply wouldn't
mention events of stargate sg1 sg
universe or sg atlantis we wouldn't see
spaceships built by the toweri or any
real specific events that happened
within the tv series so even though they
won't necessarily acknowledge the tv
series they'll be very careful not to
have anything in the movie that tramples
on what happened in the tv series so
even though they won't reference what
happened like the replicates and said
this they won't reference that it didn't
happen either so the storyline is being
reworked and re-formatted
so that it can really fit nicely in
between both the movie could be a
standalone project
something that could be referenced in
future series but that basically
wouldn't trample over what's come before
now i think that's a really interesting
way of doing it i think
if it was alongside a television series
that is is a continuation of the story
that works well for me
i have absolutely no problem with kurt
russell returning as general o'neal at
the end of the day they both played the
part so if richard dean anderson doesn't
want to do it then so be it um
we switched actors before so why not
just switch back the main thing for me
though is that a movie is an hour and a
half
it can be one specific story it can be a
throwback to the original movie and if
they do it right it doesn't have to
trample over the canon that we love
but a tv series must be a continuation
of the story
we can not just forget the sg-1 ever
existed and we cannot ever just erase
that
15 years of television
so
for me
a movie can be this side project it can
be a bit of fun and it can be something
that harks back to the original movie a
movie that you have to remember is mgm's
10th highest-grossing movie of all time
as long as the tv series is a
continuation of brad wright's original
series i should also mention though that
it has been mentioned to me more than
once now
that amazon are looking at what kurtzman
has done with star trek and that they
consider that to be a model for how to
move forwards with stargate
now i haven't had any specifics on what
that exactly means but to me that means
that this will be sort of a
hybridization of canon that they will
come back with a new project that they
won't worry too much about canon when it
hampers the future story
um but they will reference canon
repeatedly to try to keep the original
fans happy
i'm not quite sure how i feel about that
strange new worlds is a very good show
it kind of messes with canon but it
references canon as well so
it does keep us happy but the characters
are so good that we don't mind too much
discovery
the characters are boring and it does
peel over cannon constantly and even
though it references things from the
original so to try and keep us happy it
doesn't do it in a very good way so for
me if they do this hybridized thing that
they seem to want to do
i'm in two minds about whether it could
work or not it really basically comes
down to the showrunner and the writers
and whether
if it's not brad they get somebody that
loves the show and loves the ideas but
maybe just want to bring something new
but does it in a way that doesn't piss
all of us off so if you are new to the
channel please go to side dash track dot
com for merchandise you can pick your
team i'm personally in sg wanna and you
can also pick an sgu and sga also if you
like the content please consider
becoming a fully fledged site tracker
please hit the join button
as always guys please stay safe and um
keep up the twitter storm keep tweeting
out there
we once target because they are
listening
please stay safe i'll see you soon
[Music]
you